shalinka
last year more than 200 girls were
abducted in chibok in northeastern
Nigeria you said if we don't find these
students Nigeria as a hopeless country
now one year later there's still no sign
of the students its Nigeria at failed
state nigeria is aspiring very hard to
become a failed state I wouldn't call it
a failed state just yet
I cannot say I'm so hopeful that we'll
even find the majority of them but it
happened as I said it's a block the
block under any kind of national sense
of belonging
now the multinational force seems to be
quite successful in its mission - to
fight Boko Haram do you think we might
be witnessing the beginning of the ends
of the terrorist threat in Nigeria it
will take a generation at least to
exterminate this phenomenon altogether
at least a full generation because it's
already embedded in human society up
there in nearly Nigeria so when I look
at the military current military
successes this should not have had to
cook with Boko Haram on this level if
the proper action have been taken of the
writer this is the biggest problem I
have with the Jonathan the government
among other issues do not really have a
choice in this upcoming election in my
view in our state of this often the
present government has performed
lamented late on the other hand the main
opposition leader has a record which is
not one which any candidate should be
proud of and is that one
- which one leaps as ah this is the
answer there are things behind the scene
and there have been meetings names have
been named have taken the trouble to
check on on these details I'm speaking
publicly about her for the first time
only because I am absolutely satisfied
and I have the details absurd moves by
some ex-military officers from security
officers who even attend to push aside
the political context ins and use the
unrest as an excuse to hold and enter to
establish an interim government so you
think there might be a chance of a
military coup in Nigeria very soon the
interesting thing about this is that the
nature of the interim government wants
to pretend that it's not really a
military the interregnum different in
law but a number of thing shall we say
public political leaders well-known
civil civilians first to give the veneer
of civilian texture but basically it's a
kind of military intervention professor
shalinka thank you very much